chers compatriotes comme vous le savez
la france est frappée de plein fouet par
la pandémie de corona violences le
président de la république a pris jeudi
des mesures fortes qui ont été complétés
hier soir par le premier ministre il
nous faut tout faire pour freiner la
propagation de ce virus
et pour cela il s'agit d'abord d'être
solidaire en respectant les gestes
barrière ses gestes sont essentiels ils
sont simples respectant les gens insiste
sur ce point
j'en appelle à votre citoyenneté je sais
qu'il est difficile de renoncer à
certaines habitudes mais c'est pourtant
essentiel nos territoires d'outre-mer ne
sont pas épargnés par cette pandémie qui
s'ajoute à l'épidémie de dengue pour
certains aussi après avoir réuni cet
après-midi les préfets des drames de
saint-barthélemy de saint-martin et de
saint-pierre-et-miquelon
j'ai décidé en accord avec le premier
ministre que les mesures qu'il a
annoncées hier s'appliquerait tout à
compter de ce soir dans ces territoires
ainsi les lieux recevant du public non
indispensables à la vie du pays seront
fermés jusqu'à nouvel ordre tous les
services essentiels à la vie de nos
concitoyens restaurants ouverts mais je
vous demande dans la mesure du possible
de limiter vos déplacements au strict
nécessaire
j'ai une pensée pour tous les enfants
qui dès demain restaurant chez eux
je rappelle que ce ne sont pas des
vacances et qu'on lien avec le rectorat
les chefs d'établissement et les
professeurs sera organisée une
continuité éducative jeu c'est l'effort
qu'il vous est demandé j'en mesure les
sacrifices mais il nous apparaît que la
meilleure façon de freiner l'épidémie
est de garder une certaine distance
entre chacun de nous le premier ministre
a été clair ce que nous devons faire en
ce moment c'est tout simplement d'éviter
au maximum de se rassembler de limiter
les réunions amicales et familiales de
n'utiliser les transports en commun que
pour aller au travail et seulement et
seulement si la présence physique au
travail est indispensable de ne sortir
de chez soi que pour faire ses courses
essentiel est de faire un peu d'exercice
je vous demande aussi d'avoir une
attention particulière pour les
personnes fragiles et notamment pour nos
anciens
il faut les protéger je demande aux
entreprises aux administrations de d
loupé massivement le télétravail pour
permettre un maximum de gens de rester à
leur domicile et ce dès lundi j'ai
demandé au préfet en lien avec les
agences de santé et les élus des
territoires de prendre toutes les
initiatives utiles pour adapter ces
mesures aux réalités de nos territoires
et de mettre en place des mesures
complémentaires utiles à votre vie
quotidienne
mes chers compatriotes l'implication de
tous pour le respect strict de ces
mesures permettra de limiter la
diffusion du virus et le développement
de l'épidémie
je vous remercie